that he's a cancer. He's AIDS.
He is hepatitis.
He is herpes that kills you. And I'm going to assume that you're
a naive liberal who just falls
manipulation from this slur. You are so
naive about it and it's goddamn
>> Cool. So this is Counter Points went on a bit of a of
a rant about Hasan and I thought maybe we check it out. Maybe
we check out how the other side lives. What are they saying?
You know, I think he makes some reasonably good points about
Hasan. Like points that you have to contend with. This is if
you want to know what points you're going to be contending with
next,
Counter Points is like a Hasan hater. He will absolutely know
them. He'll know them like on the like like the back of his hand,
okay? So we'll give it a quick listen.
But if you want people outside of the sanitized Ezra Klein New
York Times fan base, then click on this spicy title helps. And
the spicy title
Hasan [__] is not your enemy.
But since I know that Ezra Klein watches every single one of
my episodes, he's a huge fan of the show, okay? He's a huge fan
of the show and I know he's going to watch this. So I'm going
to share this with him. Ezra Klein, the body of your work is
unobjectionable. Is [__] a hater as Third Way alleges?
In an interview with the writer Aaron Rabinberg, [__]
addressed some of his worst comments. I find some of his answers
compelling and others less so. The comparison of liberal Zionists
to Nazis, for instance, is repugnant and not so much improved
by [__] clarifying that he opposes ethno-states.
But to focus on the on only those comments is to miss much else
that [__] has said and believes. He has also said,
"From pogroms to the Holocaust to have always been singled out
by those as in power as a scapegoat for the instability and economic
volatility that the people in power caused." A resilient nation
anti-semitism is a constant threat. He has called anti-semitism
gross, immoral, and a hate crime. He has promoted Jon Ossoff,
a Democratic senator from Georgia who's as a 2028 presidential
possibility. In previous presidential primaries, [__]
supported Bernie Sanders who is also It is an unusual form of
patriot that calls out anti-semitism and promotes Americans for
the presidency.
Very curious, isn't it?
>> Just a totally
just a totally disgusting anti-semitism where he just keeps supporting
to run the country. Very crazy, very gross.
Very gross.
Ezra Klein, the body of your work is unobjectionable,
okay? The previous title was hyper objectionable, but it did
get me to click on your article. And the previous headline was
Hasan [__] is not your enemy. And I want to explain
to you real quick
that why that title was 100% incorrect.
Hasan [__]
was born to Mehmet [__] out of Turkey. He's actually
unironically an anchor
He was flown to the United States, born in New Jersey, flown
back, and then he was raised in Turkey and his dad is like a
billionaire sitting on the Chamber of Commerce for Turkey and
he seems to have Mehmet [__] seems to have some pretty
negative opinions about the United States of America and raised
Hasan [__] in that culture.
Hasan came to the University of Miami, partied at the University
of Miami, got a geopol degree, and basically worked at his uncle's
media company, The Young Turks. And once again, I find Cenk Uygur
less objectionable than Hasan [__] but Okay, hold
on. Now, hold on cuz that's very funny to listen to right off
the start. Is he like he's not saying it, but is he trying to
make it seem like Hasan was brought to the United States like
they had him in the United States so he could be like an
Is this like secret agent Hasan theory coming out now? Cuz like
I feel like it's sort of implied,
but there's no way they're really implying that, right? There's
no possible way that we're going with Hasan [__]
is actually a secret agent. What part of the being the secret
agent involved saying America deserved 9/11? That seems like
a real secret agent thing to say. They'll never know that I'm
actually wanting to destroy America. AMERICA DESERVED 9 DUDE,
I'M GOING TO SAY IT. AMERICA DESERVED 9/11.
They'll never know that I'm an That's really? That seems a little
on the nose, no? And basically worked at his uncle's media company,
The Young Turks. And once again, I find Cenk Uygur less objectionable
than Hasan [__] but Hasan [__] crafted
a livestream
He is an unapologetic
authorit- Well, maybe he's an apologetic
authoritarian communist.
What I mean by that is that he has been on shows,
not only well, actually on his own show, he's simped and swept
for the Soviet Union of the 20th century. He has simped and swept
for the CCP both in the 20th century and in the modern era. He
has traveled to modern China. He has uh simped for them while
in China, which is effectively like an
police state
likely uh guilty of a cultural genocide in reference to the Uyghur
Muslims and also illegal organ harvesting in reference to the
Falun Gong religious minority. And
Okay. I've not seen this. I would love if he had clips for this
stuff.
Cuz like again,
uh it's it's very much the same thing. So Ezra talks about how
I'm not going to you know, I'm not going to listen to 30-second
clips. If you could find Hasan consistently doing this, like
consistently
over and over again doing some of these things, then maybe start
to build up a case for like, oh I And by the way, on the China
front, in terms of sweeping for China or simping for China, I
mean guilty on all charges. He's absolutely guilty, right? If
that's enough for you to say that he loves authoritarianism and
he hates America, he hates democracy,
then I don't know. Like you you proved your point. If that if
that's the point you want to make is his love or his like weird,
you know, larping
with regards to China and their popular their popular revolution.
If you think that's enough to say he hates democracy and he wants
to destroy America, then I guess you've proven that. That one
I'll give you. But a lot of the other stuff I would need to see
clips on. And not just clips, but like him reiterating and reiterating
and reiterating the same point. He sweeps for that. He actually
sweeps for the state incarcerating people based off of religious
and political ideas and then stealing the euthanizing them and
then stealing their organs. He's minimized that story. He's pretended
it's
Meanwhile, if you actually check out United Nations reporting,
the United Nations reporting is quite convinced that this is
true. And not only is that true, but the cultural genocide is
inarguable.
So again, I guess we'd have to go through This is like a lot
to build up, right? So you're building all of this stuff up.
I understand that a lot of Hasan's audience would say this is
all, you like propaganda against China. You know what I'm saying?
I understand that's how they they'd see this. I feel like this
only
It's like the narrative you have, I need to see a lot of it borne
out in at least a few places,
Like I I need to see what reporting is he talking about. I guess.
So my my problem with this so far is I just don't know a lot
of the stuff he's referencing. Hasan [__] clicked
on a article that said "Tourism returns to
And it was about a person going to Xinjiang and trying to talk
to people, which is the province where Uyghur Muslims are, trying
to talk to people about the cultural genocide that happened in
Xinjiang. And effectively, the second they started asking locals
about the cultural genocide, a CCP
basically somebody who wanted to, you know, like make sure that
they weren't asking the wrong questions,
started following them around town. Basically standing a foot
away from the community members that they wanted to interview
about the cultural genocide in Xinjiang. And the way that Hasan
[__] characterized that article was like, "Oh yeah,
tourism is back in Xinjiang. There's no cultural genocide. Who
gives
And like honestly, I'm trying to resist using like homophobic
against Hasan [__] right now because I I I got to
see the clips on this. By the way, if this is so easy to prove,
I just wonder why this isn't getting used. This is such a This
is so much better a narrative to me. Why does this never get
put together into like a convincing
set of clips to make this point about Hasan?
I actually don't know cuz to me if all of this stuff,
cultural genocide this guy woke scold. I mean cultural genocide
is real. Yeah, I Listen, if he was a Canadian conservative, we
could make this criticism that he doesn't believe in those cuz
Canadian conservatives said this this wasn't real with regards
to the Native Americans in Canada for a long time. Okay? Even
though it was like very obvious in the policy, but they said
it for a long time.
but I don't know if Connor believes that. He might think cultural
genocide is real. That's so repulsive. I can't even believe he
has the Oh yeah, I was saying that I just don't know why this
isn't put together into a more coherent narrative. Like take
the take the videos you have and then just cuz here's what they
want.
They want to have like a couple out of context clips to do their
propaganda with. If they put together one cohesive
I do think
that it would fall apart. Hasan would just go, "Here's what I
Here's what I said, here's what I mean, and here's what I actually
think." And I'm guessing he doesn't actually think the things
that they're laying out, and it would disappear, right? It would
It would be the same thing as what's happening now.
But like, don't put it together into a coherent narrative. Don't
put it together in one whole thing, cuz I That would be very
inconvenient for us,
[__] balls to say what he says about Israel-Palestine
while sweeping for the CCP. But anyways, not only that, he's
truly an anti-American imperialist.
And And what I mean by that, American imperialism,
we live in a world that is dominated by the American security
establishment and international commerce, and he would truly
like to see the American empire
folded.
He would like to see our military capacities eroded, us withdraw
from Eurasia,
whatever happens after that, if China swallows parts of Eurasia,
who gives a [__] If Russia swallow parts of Eurasia,
who gives a [__] If Russia
goes and annihilates Ukraine, who gives a [__]
I don't think this is true. I think this is where we're starting
to get into the fantastical element, at least with regards to
Ukraine and Russia.
uh Taiwan is the place you should argue this. If you were going
to argue this against Hasan, it should be really centered on
China and Taiwan, cuz I do
that he's got a very
His argument about the Han ethnicity being in both places
was very very weird to me, to be honest with you. That was very
weird. I think if you keep it to China and Taiwan, or Nepal or
Tibet, yeah, sure. And the the imperialism that China's done
there, although he has Hasan has straight-up defended, I believe,
the Nepalese imperialism from China, right? Like, wasn't the
response to the the Nepal stuff or the Tibet stuff? I can't remember
which one, but it was basically like they were they were literally
like there, and so China civilized them. Like, I think he literally
gave quite Like, it was the most American moment in Hasan's life,
to be honest with you. He was like, "Yeah, they were like they
were like people, they were like kids. We had to We had to fix
it." It's like, dude,
>> this guy does love America. Yeah, Tibet because of the
slave cast they had. It's just very funny to me that he he suddenly
like switched up a lot. Okay, they had slaves, he said. Well,
I've heard this rant before, but it it just gets like a little
fantastical when you start to include Russia. That's you, you
know, using your pet issues to go after and continue to to hold
viewers who are like very concerned about
I don't think that one's anywhere near as well sourced, unfortunately.
It's It's all in the China stuff if you want to prove any of
this this [__] but I I don't think it proves what
you say. I think it proves like a lot of bias for believing the
most favorable narratives for China. I don't think it broadly
proves that Hasan wants like a an authoritarian regime in America,
or that he wants democracy destroyed. He may want to see American
influence eroded, but that's because he believes I That's To
my belief, is he believes that American influence has been incredibly
And it's basically like, "Stop harming other places for your
own country." Anyway, we continue. >> Realistically, the
greater evil of American empire will have been defeated, and
so the tens of thousands, hundreds of thousands, probably millions
who would die It has been Well, hold on. Then if you want to
say that American influence has been that bad, if you want to
say that American influence has been like a broad detriment to
the world and all of this stuff, and that Americans only live
so high on the hog, they only have the standard of living they
do because of exploitation of the third world, of the global
south, then you are inherently arguing to further degrade the
means, further degrade the material conditions of the American
people at the benefit for the benefit of the rest of the world,
and good luck winning an election on that. And I believe if you
believe that, you should be running on it and making the moral
argument. You will lose horribly, you'll never win a single seat,
but
you know what I'm saying? Like, you you've lost already. If you
If you want to make that argument, you want to try to put that
to the American people,
right? We have to stop exploiting the global south, we have to
stop all these bad practices, then your lifestyle will crash
in America, and I think that is broadly what is causing the American
people to enter into this new phase where they are way more open
to certain ideas than they were before. Like, it has to be a
slow transition off that path. It can't be like, "We need to
take control and pull back from all of this, right?" Obviously.
That's what you have to be talking about. And you have to have
some idea of where it's going. You can't just say that this is
like the worst thing that's ever happened and and America's responsible
for all evils and have no way of defending why American people
should vote for you. Other than it's just the moral thing to
do, sacrifice your your like way of life, your your standard
of living to support the rest of the world. That's That's never
going to win in America. You will You will have lost. You will
have lost entirely on that
through the transition of American imperium into whatever the
Chinese,
Russian, American multipolar planet.
He doesn't give a [__] He thinks it's ne- He thinks
it's a necessary evil, and I think he's a [__] for
that. Um so, we got simping for authoritarian communism. We got
Oh, okay, okay. We We didn't even get to this. So, Ezra, still
still trying to talk to Ezra real quick.
He has said this openly
on a podcast
with Marxist-Leninist
Hakim from Iraq and Marxist-Leninist Second Thought, somebody
who wants to live in an anarcho-communist society where if you
don't like anarchism or communism, you should be sent to a re-
>> Dude, why does it matter who he said
and Marxist-Leninist
Second Thought, somebody who wants to live in an
society where if you don't like anarchism or communism, you should
be sent to a re-education camp and effectively re-educated of
out of your anti-communist ways. He has said that he pretends
to be a liberal progressive social democrat whenever he goes
onto liberal platforms.
This is the part where I want I want Connor to make the video
and make this argument.
Right? I want I want somebody to put it together, make this argument
that Hasan did this. I want someone to do it, cuz every time
I watch people do it, they're not making like a direct argument,
they're sort of like hinting at stuff, they're putting a bunch
of disparate things together, and they're trying to say, "And
obviously overall, this means he's hiding his power level." I've
watched that I've watched that Deep Program podcast episode.
I've watched the whole thing. That's not what's being said there.
I think this is broadly just a misnomer.
Even though Hasan does mask up Like, Hasan does, you know, talk
in a more reasonable way when he goes on platforms, in the same
way every influencer who wants to grow does.
Right? Like, so I'm not saying he doesn't, you know, hide his
power level a little bit when he goes on other podcasts. He obviously
does.
I'm just saying that it's not him hiding his power level as a
like a revolutionary communist. It's him hiding his power level
in terms of like he probably He probably still stands behind
that America deserved 9/11. Dude, I'm saying it. Dude, I'm saying
it. America deserved 9/11, man. That Yeah, he probably still
stands behind that in terms of the blowback, in terms of like
everything they've done in the Middle East has actually been
incredibly like cataclysmic over there, and America should know
some kind of pain for that broadly, right? I'm But he's going
to say, "No, I totally disavow that. That was a [__]
up thing to say." cuz he's trying to not
get totally cooked, right? Or even not disavow, but I meant something
else. I meant blowback and blah blah blah blah blah. Okay?
But like, everybody does that when they go on a random podcast.
They're They're all going to hide their power level. It's not
really something unique or special that you say that.
It's just not.
in order to sucker in center-left
fools
to consistently consume his content so he can radicalize them
into being leftists.
That way, they can go on to consume actual Marxist-Leninist content.
He God, I've been sent this Hold on. Let me see. Let me see if
I can find it really quickly, cuz I've been sent the timestamp
for the Deep Program thing, and I think this would be a good
time to watch it. to sucker in center-left
fools
to consistently consume his content so he can radicalize them
into being leftists.
That way, they can go on to consume actual Marxist-Leninist content.
He's not a liberal. He's not a democrat.
He's a socialist or a communist.
He's a Marxist-Leninist. He does apologia for these [__]
That doesn't even get into Israel-Palestine. I see people with
the baby settlers clip. Uh around 35 minutes during one of his
Deep Program appearances is when they start talking about the
ultimate goal, and Hasan talks about pushing for social dem-
democratic policies as a stepping stone to more revolutionary
attitudes. He is not shy about his motives in this video. But
does he say that that's his motive, or is he saying, "You guys
should support me, and your audience should support me, because
either way you cut it, if we do more social democratic policies,
that helps you guys. That moves people in your direction." I
don't agree with you necessarily, but no matter what, we're both
going in the same direction. We want more social democratic policies
as a gateway to like our ultimate system that we want. Either
way, it pushes more in this direction. Yeah, I mean, for me,
it was pretty run-of-the-mill radicalization process, you know,
Bernie came around, and I was like, "Oh, wow, he's saying stuff
I haven't heard before. Yeah, why is our healthcare
Sorry, it is
Is the idea that he's like propagandizing people? Sorry, you're
No one denies communism is Hasan's ultimate goal. It's about
whether or not he wants to bring about revolution, like have
revolutionary attitudes, and destroy democracy, right?
But it that's what that's where the difference is. And I think
he I think he does say that he draws a divider. I think he says
it in this video, but I can't remember for sure.
so expensive, stuff like that. And you know, you know how it
goes. I would I would I heard the rhetoric like, "Oh, he's not
actually a socialist. He's a a social democrat." I'm like, "Okay,
what's the difference between social democracy and socialism?"
And then I'd, you know, read a little bit more about that. That's
very interesting. so many people simultaneously consider me to
be a Democratic Party mouthpiece or a succdem or whatever the
but also a threat to America as well, because I I do, just like
you said, I do advocate for social democratic reforms, and I
do think that in order to develop any kind of mechanism of pushback,
a robust labor force that has any kind of, you know, speaking
power, any kind of fighting power to strike at the heart of the
the imperial core where values generated, I I think that in the
short term, in order to combat against that, you you have to
advocate for a much lighter form of of propaganda. Despite, you
know, I I perfectly understand that social democracies
benefit tremendously from American imperialism, Western imperialism,
and and would not exist in the way that they do without such
atrocities committed, right? But you know, if you want America
in the way that I feel about it, and if you want America to get
out of the way for places with more revolutionary potential to
do what they would normally do, I think that, you know, one thing
you have to do is is is advocate for a lighter form while simultaneously
still doing agitated propaganda that goes beyond, you know, Right.
>> social democratic ideas. I just wanted to like put emphasis
on
So, that is about
to me, that is him arguing,
right, for social He's saying, "I vote I advocate for social
democratic policies, because in order for America to have a middle
class that can actually stand up and have a valuable voice, we
need like a a broader a better middle class, a stronger middle
class, a more economically like valuable middle class.
that I don't think anybody disagrees with that. He says, "That
is required to let America get out of the way for other places
where actual like revolution could take place." So, he's referring
to basically America's interventions in places that have nationalized
right? That's clearly what he's referring to there.
And he says, "So, we'd have to go from there onto whatever else."
But he's saying, "We need social democratic policies in America
so that the middle class is valuable, their voices are valuable,
so that we can actually get America we can convince people to
like get out of the way, to change opinions in the imperial core
where everybody's super happy and nothing's getting messed with,
right? Like everybody benefits massively from the status quo.
It's funny because I basically just said that to you guys, that
if you are advocating like entirely for getting America out of
the way immediately as a first step, you will lose every election.
Now, if you want to say that's holding back your power level,
to me, the power level thing that's getting held back that has
to be getting withheld is that you want eventually to have a
violent revolution in America, right? If it's just I think if
we get, you know, people more well-adjusted, but if we get people
in a better place economically where they don't feel like they're
having to fight for their lives every day, then eventually they'll
like those they'll like those policies, they'll like that general
attitude in the world, and they will want other people to be
raised up the same way. There's two different ways of looking
at that. It's very hard to understand,
right? It's very hard to understand like where he's coming from
at this point.
Anyway, the exact point of the so-called radicalization funnel
where, for example, Hasan and JT catch them while they're young,
as they say, and then they start looking into this new idea,
etc., etc., and then move forwards through the funnel, get more
and more informed, get more and more radicalized, and so on,
can only work and can absolutely utilize, for example, the stuff
that that Hasan does because Hasan does one very particular thing
social democrats that, for example, would never call to this
podcast or we would give a little [__] to. Because
they they they they cut the the the funnel from both sides. What
what do I mean by this? They introduce people to, you know, lukewarm
socialist ideas, etc., etc., and then they want to keep them
there. Yeah. Right? Well, whenever Hasan introduces people to
socialist ideas, yes, the the lukewarm
ones, you know, keeping your power levels low, it's hidden, and
so on, and so on. He does not stop them from progressing through
the funnel and getting additional and additional information,
and so on. He doesn't agitate against, for example, the the revolutionary
perspective, and so on, and so on. Yeah.
You do your part in the funnel for the cause or whatever the
[__] you want to call it. We'll talk later about,
you know, if what we're doing actually does anything, etc., etc.,
but
as long as it you do not try to keep people exactly there where
you where you want them and don't want them to evolve, etc.,
etc.,
you're doing my modest opinion, a great great thing for the cause.
So, Hakim says, I think this is Hakim, is saying, "Okay, you
hide your power level." So, it's not even Hasan saying he hides
his power level. It's Hakim saying you hide your power level,
okay?
And Hasan's saying like Oh, sorry. Hasan really hasn't said much
here. But Hakim's saying, "Okay, as long as you don't cut people
off from us, as long as you're willing to acknowledge us and
not pretend that we're like some great evil, then we appreciate
you." As opposed to like a lot of other people, social democratic
politicians and influencers, who would say that we're like beyond
evil. They never want anything to do with us, right? Yeah, so
while doing all this [__] as if this wasn't bad enough.
This isn't even his spicy clips. This is just his
Right? That's why I'm saying Hasan [__] is not your
enemy, as the original title, is the kind of naivete
and stupidity that I expect out of liberals, to be honest.
Just being real, chat. This is why I don't want to be I don't
want to be like, "Yeah, I'm a liberal.
I'm a pro-gun Oh. Oh, I see. Most Most watch because Hasan talks
about socialist to poor stupid. Yeah, okay. So, most people watch
to laugh at Hasan saying like if the people who actually make
fun of my house are
>> I'm liberal. I like This is like this very common reaction
to make it so that the people you dislike, people who are arguing
something about you, you There's a There's a common thing people
try to do. They make it like morally wrong. It seems like influencers
do this a lot. Actually, your criticism there was morally incorrect.
You're like literally doing a moral wrong by making this criticism
of me. I just It basically anytime somebody's ever done that
to me, I'm like, "Oh, it's that's kind of It's obviously What
are you saying?" I expect out of liberals, to be honest.
Just being real, chat. This is why I don't want to be I don't
want to be like, "Yeah, I'm a liberal.
I'm a pro-gun liberal. I like I believe he said he definitely
said he would vote for JD over Kamala. like weed and gay people
and blacks and Hispanics. I just happen to like guns. You know
why I don't want to say that because some of you
and I include Ezra Klein in this or whoever titled the article
that way are
naive
about the threat to your left.
You are so
naive about it, and it's goddamn infuriating. So, let's do a
little Israel-Palestine
analysis.
Okay? Oh, there's more. >> So, Hasan [__] while
claiming that he doesn't believe in this, he
minimized the assaults and and murders of October 7, 2023.
He said that this was a predictable outcome as a result of the
repression of Israel, which is true. Okay. But then For a second,
I I paused there and I'm like, "Wait, I should let him finish
cuz holy fuck."
propagated
the conspiracy theory that the vast majority of the civilian
casualties on October 7, 2023 >> I'll link this. Link this.
I feel like Hasan tried to stay away from this very
I I feel like Hasan tried to stay away from this very explicitly.
Did he really do it? There's no way, right? There's no possible
way that Hasan, and I've never seen this before, Hasan goes,
"Bro, good one. Hannibal doctrine. Israel killed everyone. There's
no possible way." Hasan Conor's saying that Hasan invoked Hannibal
doctrine to say that um Israelis killed most of the people dead
on October 7th.
I'm like, "I don't I don't think that's true. I think I would
have seen that if that were true."
Hasan was insensitive about the Yes.
>> result of the repression of Israel, which is true. But
then he
propagated
the conspiracy theory that the vast majority of the civilian
casualties on October 7, 2023 were Israel's own armed forces.
So, that this is what happened according to Hasan [__]
So, Hamas freedom fighters,
the moral force in Israel-Palestine, I [__] you not.
He has said that between the lesser of two evils, between the
I I'm sorry, it's just true. I I I know that we don't like
Like the the thing should be here, it's not that he's saying
Everybody misunderstands. Like if Hasan was saying between the
Nazis and Hamas, I'm a lesser evil voter, I'm voting for Hamas,
nobody would bat an eye. The whole point is that he's saying
Israel is way more evil than any of you will
So evil, in fact, that even after October 7th, Hamas is the lesser
evil in the region.
That's how evil is Israel is. But nobody's Everybody's taking
that to mean Israel's our greatest ally, and and Hasan's saying
that Hamas is better than them. How?
It's It says way more It says everything about Israel, almost
nothing about
People just can't handle it. They can't do it. IDF and Hamas,
Hamas is the lesser of two evils. So, let's go ahead and run
down what he implies and has sometimes outright stated happened
on October 7th, 2023.
So, brave Mujahideen Hamas fighters crossed into southern Israel
and they didn't kill any Did he refer to them as brave Mujahideen
fighters? Civilians.
They were played I dude, Hassan would be and I I specifically
Did Do we really believe Okay. Do we really believe that Hassan
did this and Dan Saltman was incapable of finding these clips?
Are we living in a world
Are we living in a world where Dan Saltman failed to find these
clips of all people? I I don't believe it. I don't believe that
Connor's been holding back a bunch of clips of Hassan saying
all this crazy denying that any civilians were killed by Hamas
fighters?
I I can't I can't see it. Okay. Perfect gentlemen. They didn't
hurt anybody. They didn't shoot anybody. Any any footage to the
contrary is an exception and not the rule. Okay? Those were a
few bad hombres, but realistically Hamas are moral freedom
They kidnapped
a bunch of Israeli citizens in order to use as hostages
for a political prisoner
And then as they were traveling using the Samson protocol or
whatever the [__] they call it, just open fire and
massacred everyone. Okay? Is the civilians didn't die because
of
The IDF just hit every person traveling south with Apache Hellfire
missiles and 20 mm chain gun rounds and realistically
out of the 900 civilians that died on October 7th, 2023.
Yeah, I like the thing is there are people like the Aaron Maté
guy almost certainly believes I was watching a little while back.
I think it was the Aaron Maté and Ana Kasparian Piers panel.
I think the Aaron Maté guy believes this
But Hassan doesn't believe it. I've never seen well, or I have
somehow missed the clip in all the A logging I've done, Dan's
done, everyone's done. We've missed it.
Now, it's possible that Hassan referenced that he thinks some
people were killed by helicopters, but realistically that's almost
certainly
Like that's almost certainly true that they would have opened
up fire on some people getting taken into into Gaza and like
some hostages could have been killed, but it's like dude, it's
like got to be such a small number. It's not worth bringing up.
You just kind of look deranged bringing it up, right?
Yeah, you just look deranged bringing it up. So, like if if somebody
said that's not true at all and Hassan pushed back and said,
"Well, it's probably true a little bit." I I'm fine with that,
but then to try to make it like some moral point off of that
that Israel doesn't even care about its own civilians and they
were willing willing to kill all these people. I just don't think
that's I that's an unproductive conversation at best.
And at at worst, you just look like a pretty heartless person,
especially if that's close to October 7th making that argument.
Maybe 30 of them were killed
Didn't he just say yesterday in Pod Save that 1/3 were killed
by were military implying that 2/3 weren't? Yes, he obviously
now
obviously in any clip I've ever seen of Hassan talking about
it, he has reported just the numbers. Like the numbers everybody
agrees on. So, I don't know where the again, it must have been
really close to October >> by Hamas, you know, the ones
that you have on camera, but 870 of them were killed by the IDF.
Hannibal, that's what it was. It was the Hannibal protocol.
doctrine. Okay?
um basically the IDF despite only killing, I say only,
the Gaza has a population of 2.2 million
and 70 God, there's no way. Oh, no, please Connor, do not try
to make a most moral argument at this point. There's no way he's
going to do Guys, it's actually really impressive that they only
killed 70,000 civilians in in the entire time that It's actually
really impressive that they've only killed this many There's
no way. There's no way. There's just no also has a population
of 2.2 million people. Please. And 70,000 have died in direct
conflict, 20,000 of whom are allegedly uh combatants and then
200,000 are likely to die as a result of indirect consequences.
And by the way, I am a critic of what Israel has done in Palestine.
I know I I still I know I still have Ezra Klein's undivided
What are you a critic of? Cuz you're you're about to say some
[__]
that is totally insane. I can tell. And for you to go, "Well,
I'm a critic." You are worse than Hassan. By the way, if you
run defense for Israel's actions, even this tacit defense, you
are engaging in the exact thing you're criticizing Hassan for
except by like an order of magnitude worse. So, [__]
off with all of the criticism about his opinion on Hamas versus
Israel. Get the [__] out of here, okay?
That's assuming I'm not just Maybe I'm just like way I'm hearing
all these trigger words and maybe I am just getting triggered,
okay? Maybe I am becoming a leftist. I am an SJW now. I am extremely
triggered
cuz I see everything being said in the lead up to this is him
preparing to do some sweep for Israel. I can tell. I feel it.
So,
what happened after that was the Israelis just came in and genocided
everybody. Okay? They just what They saw a man, a woman, a child
and they just in the face. And they just took 500,000 lb 2,000
lb bombs and they just dropped it on every single building. And
they uh basically Cuz that's the only thing that That's the only
way people see it and we couldn't have a much more nuanced view
of it and still think that's monstrous, right?
Like Like he's saying, this is what they have to do is they have
to make this hyperbole. They make up this hyperbole, right? Of
Well, you just think they they found they they do like intelligence
gathering just to find like maternity
and bomb them. It's like, okay, well, let's say they didn't do
that, but did something that are like extremely
barbaric and evil anyway. I Like they have to pretend you're
doing the most hyperbolic version of the argument to even attempt
this.
What happened after that was the Israelis just came in and genocided
everybody. Okay? They just what They saw a man, a woman, a child
and they just shot them in the face. And they just took 500,000
lb 2,000 lb bombs and they just dropped it on every single building.
And they basically had drones with guns on them that flew around
and shot, you know, five-year-olds in the back of the head. And
they used cluster munitions and bombs and tank shells and manpads
and rockets and drones in order to rape and murder everyone inside
Gaza. Okay? Everyone in Gaza right now is dead.
Literally nobody thinks this. This is a not even not the most
deranged person thinks this.
What he doesn't understand here is as people get more invested
in this, they get more invested in being accurate as well. And
so, accurate in terms of like numbers and knowing like how many
people have died, they might get they might get like hyperbolic,
but they they do want to know what's going on here. People do
look up information to figure out what's going on here. I What
is What is she say? They They're focused on being directionally
correct. They're not saying every Gazan is dead. Nobody thinks
every Gazan is dead, which is why there's still like a urgency
in fixing and trying to do what you can to prevent the situation
from worsening. Nobody thinks that. Like that's not The level
of outrage from people is calibrated appropriately to what has
actually happened. Nobody's outrage is based on every single
man, woman, and child dying.
I will say there is an element of this, right? I do think that
people talk about the intent. Well, we Hamas is so bad because
they'd kill every Israeli. I think that from top to bottom in
the Israel in the Israeli government, you have that same attitude.
They're just smarter about saying it, not saying it. Okay? From
top to bottom in that government, all of their major officials
are totally fine with the the complete extinction of Palestinians.
It's just about managing other expectations of other countries.
That is their That's their mitigating factor is America. Is how
much other countries will disavow them or or make them a pariah
state based on what they're going to do in Gaza. That is the
only mitigating factor. They have every bit the genocidal intent
Hamas does towards them. I don't know why we would pretend
it's the moral equivalent to the Holocaust. So, the way that
the Germans
industrially slaughtered
in World War II is identical
to the way that >> the entire straw man constructed here
is
This is This is what you have to do to defend Israel though.
You just have to make things up. You have to like literally build
construct like this
never before seen a straw man of proportions never before seen,
okay?
To fight against to try to pretend that there's something to
defend in the actions of Israel at this point. at the IDF Critical
of Israel, by the way. Critical of Israel, okay? has slaughtered
the entire population of
that's effectively, if you talk to a Hasan [__] fan,
that's pretty much like an analysis of what's happened.
>> Now, if you ask an inconvenient question
based on your narrative of how this happened, why do we have
tons of footage of Hamas like massacring people? Why do we have
tons of footage of Hamas massacring children?
Why do we have tons of footage of Hamas like chopping people's
head
Wait, we have a bunch of Wait, we've got footage of Hamas massacring
children?
Where's the Where's the tons of footage? I've seen a lot of the
October 7th footage. I think you see what are implied to be like
like if you say, "Well, they're firing guns at kibbutzes." Then
sure, maybe. But like there's I'm not saying we have tons of
foot I haven't seen tons of footage of like a Hamas soldier seeing
Israeli kid and blowing them up either. Sure, or like shooting
them, whatever. I've not seen that. Maybe there is. I've just
never seen that video.
heads off. I think one of the worst things I've seen was there's
pretty clearly like a group of people hiding in a bunker or something.
And I do see them throw like grenades into the into the like
bunker they're hiding in. I've seen that, which is pretty which
is pretty terrible, right? Why do we have them gleefully parading
Israeli corpses through the streets?
Why do we have witness testimony from the day of of assaults
and and murders at the I I agree. Hold on. Wait. I think Connor
and I are going to come to the same place. I also think it would
be morally virtuous for the United States to put an arms embargo
and cut off all aid to Hamas. Thank you, Connor. Fantastic point.
I agree. No USA to Hamas.
So true. So so true. Stop giving Hamas jets and bombs and everything.
I totally He's won me over, actually.
I I do I do agree now. Hamas is
America should stop supplying bombs and providing a security
guarantee to Hamas, okay? Thank you. Thank you, Connor. Thank
you. music festival.
Why do we have women who have said that they were assaulted in
captivity?
Why do we have uh basically like Okay, so we like massacred everybody
with like drones and bombs and JDAMs and 1,000-lb There's like
literally Dude, it's so funny that there's like
Every single thing he's saying you can flip like perfectly like
one-to-one.
That's the crazy thing here. And say like at scale Israel's doing
the thing you're talking about more. bombs and 2,000-lb bombs.
How come if that's true that we have committed an identical
scenario to the Holocaust,
why out of a population of 2.2 million people are 2.1 million
people still alive? If you ask any of those questions, you're
Okay. If you ask any of those questions, you hate Arab Muslims,
you hate
um you're a monster, you're a Zionist apologist, you're a
you're a murderer, you you love you love murder, you love Holocaust.
You know. And that's the answer that you get back from these
kinds of people. So anyway, so in summary I mean, that's just
factually I'm sorry. I Again, we could just list out So he's
he's talked about October 7th. How do you deal with the difference
in scale, the numbers? How do you deal with Lebanon? Like how
do you how do you deal with any of this stuff? And by the way,
this is not talking about the property damage at all. And this
is the this is what obliterates the capitalists, okay?
You know that these are people's homes. These are villages in
southern Lebanon. Timed detonations. These homes are being detonated
at the same time. These are people's ability to live, people's
ability to have to eke out any tiny amount of happiness in the
world being wiped off the face of the earth. Who by? Well, Israel,
of course. Israel's got to do this. This is required, guys. We've
got to get rid of all the civilian
They did the same thing in Gaza. They just intentionally, when
there was no targets in the area, when they'd cleared these buildings
entirely, they detonated all homes. Why? Why would you do this
if not for evil? If not to explicitly
maintain an ethnic cleansing, to to cause an ethnic cleansing
and then maintain it. Make it so that they can never come back.
This is poisoning the wells. This is the Nakba. This is a second
Nakba,
We're watching it unfold in 4K, paid for by your tax dollars.
How in the world How in the world can you actually go on a diatribe
about Hamas at this point? Where What Where What Where are they
doing anything on this scale? I don't see it. I've never seen
it. three. Ezra Klein, cuz I know Ezra Klein has 3,000 IQ and
he's been watching this entire segment.
Hasan [__] is your enemy.
He might be useful
electorally.
He might drag He might bring enough
through his sanitized version of himself on public media. He
might drag more progressives to the polls than he alienates moderates.
I don't think that's true, but I don't have any statistics to
back up my instinct.
And so, liberals have a choice right now. The Democratic Party
has a choice. Either they accept Hasan [__] as a
necessary electoral evil, and they go onto his platform hoping
to bring some of his audience over to Democratic politics,
and they pray that he has a net positive electoral effect,
or they realize that he's a
AIDS.
He is hepatitis.
He is herpes that kills you. And then you say,
"Thanks, but no thanks."
Those are the two options. So I I do still think you should talk
to him. I do think you should debate him. I do think you should
go onto his platform. I do think you should fight him in the
marketplace of ideas. That has nothing to do with anything that
I said. But you should realize the piece of [__]
that he is. And if you don't, I'm going to question your judgment,
and I'm going to assume that you're a naive liberal who just
falls for
manipulation from this
Wow. Thanks, Ezra. I appreciate you for being a friend of the
show.
So this was Hasan Oh, sorry. This is Connor's rant about why
Hasan can't be
There's I There's the anti-Democratic bit, the pro-Hamas, pro-terrorism
bit, right, going into Israel-Palestine. I think the Israel-Palestine
stuff Connor's like obviously just wrong on. Connor's like way
off base in every possible way on the Israel-Palestine stuff.
Like way off base in terms of what Democrats want, what basically
everybody wants. He's It's really rough. That section is terrible.
The one where he could maybe you could argue he's cooking a little
bit is the China and Second Thoughts stuff. And I think there's
That's probably where their narrative is. It's just like after
after you guys totally whiff on the just like despising liberal
democracy,
right? You're going to You're going to whiff on that one. After
whiffing on the anti-Semitism allegations,
is the is the broader like public going to really believe you
if you keep going, "Guys, we have to shun Hasan because he's
an anti-Semite." Wait, no, you don't buy that one? Well, we have
to shun Hasan because he hates liberal democracy. No, you don't
buy that one? Well, we have to shun Hasan because he actually
loves China too much. It's kind of tied into the liberal democracy
bit. And he's really there's sweet for all of their
Is I I don't know. You should probably figure out the narrative
before you start this. This was the exact thing This is exactly
why the Twitch anti-Semitism stuff stalled. I truly believe that
could have worked, but they didn't know what they wanted. When
Destiny started doing this and Dan started doing this, they didn't
know what they wanted. They were all over the place. Dan was
saying, "I want a Destiny unban. Actually, I just want Dan Clancy
fired. Actually, I want different support staff. I want them
to like actually protect I want them to get rid of the word Zionist
being used negatively. Actually, I don't want them to get rid
of the word Zionist being used negatively. Actually, right?"
It's like he's switched it up a million times. And the same thing's
happening here. It's like if you don't know what you're criticizing,
you should come together and and like write some sort of essay
on this or write like a make a video essay on this. Cuz I swear
you're like all over the map, and you will fail if you just are
totally disparate. You've no like solid communication, no solid
prescription.
It will fail. It'll be over. So anyway, I I think that would
be my recommendation is is get that narrative like solidified
and figure it out.
I think it's a little rougher I'm a little concerned that I don't
think he's got a lot of citations for the points he's making
here.